freunde wir sind jetzt hier in europa
kaffee gegangen um hier einfach mal zu
frühstücken und zwar hab ich die nummer
1 frage fläche geholt das ist so mit
paar kartoffeln oder so ist das
unglaublich bacon natürlich im spiegel
zitierten sie gold das problem ist aber
ein amerikanisches männerpaar noch
bananen ich weiß nicht wann das liegt
und dann habe ich mir noch einen
blueberry überholt und ich weiß wie das
ganze schrecken aber durch schon von mir
zu sagen es schmeckt das trio mit dem
preis nicht in ordnung
lecker geschmeckt
wir stehen jetzt gerade
ähnlich eigentlich ganz spontan das hat
auch geklappt zehn minuten dahin zu
kommen sonst in unsere kredite auf 140
dollar jeweils belastet aber wieder
schaffen wir haben keine ahnung wo wir
da dinge was ich unbedingt noch sagen
muss das ganze hier ist wirklich genauso
wie in gta 4 ist einfach komplett gta 4
spielt ja hier mehr oder weniger alles
genauso aus dem gta also die komplette
landschaft hier sogar der helikopter
platz da vorne von wo wir gleich fliegen
werden sieht genauso aus wie in gta 4
safari megageil
viel spaß
einfach super komplette ruckelfrei der
typ super sympathisch der negation witz
gemacht hat und versucht innerhalb von
15 minuten alles erklären
heute bedeutet mir unglaublich das ist
so ein laden oder perry oder so da kann
man sich zur joghurt setzt form stellen
und ganz schön
denn jetzt ok 21 in central park ich
habe gerade erst mal schön gepasst
jedenfalls ist das jahr auch wieder so
super schön also sieht halt mega
idyllisch aus wir haben hier so kleine
brötchen und der uni zum kleiner fluss
und da und da geht sie zum berg hoch und
alles zum mega verwinkelt
tierfreunde sitzen hier führt das immer
noch joghurt auf der karte schon jetzt
helikopter das ist nicht weiter ruhig
helikopter
das ist nicht wahr der bleibt einfach
die ganze zeit auf einer stelle
schaut euch das er provoziert des todes
er bleibt einfach die ganze wirklichkeit
ja die ganze zeit
er bewegt sich nicht kein stückchen ich
wünsche ich könnte dann ist der weg
nicht weg lieber helikopter von dem
helikopter da oben du hast es geschafft
dort sortiert aus dem central park nach
zwei stunden erreicht
deswegen gehen wir zu viert ich wollte
gerade in dieser form laufen um eine
karte des folgenden tages ticket gekauft
aber ich habe wohl irgendwie ein
falsches ticket bekommen
deswegen laufen wir jetzt gerade weiter
richtung sub
times square erst dahinter wollen mich
gleich ins hard rock café gehen und da
laufen
und sie forscht frage kommen das ist
meine hand dagegen das ist so es ist so
dass
die 96 slade
na
sind gerade am time square dies bei
nacht und es wird einfach so aus es ist
einfach wirklich unfassbar hell
obwohl ist wirklich ein dunkel ist es
ist eigentlich dunkel aber diese
kompletten werbe reklame machen das
ganze einfach länger hell und das ist
medak wie dieser ganze platz gehört zu
den antworten schreiten durch den spruch
sagen würde dass da jetzt auch bei nacht
sometimes fördern 88 und der ausblick
auf die stadt
wir sind gerade auf dem empire state
building und ich weiß nicht das kann man
wahrscheinlich recht gut erkennen und
sieht auch einfach so krasser alles aus
schaut euch das an das sind einfach
schon hochwasser die alle so mehr als
drei meter hoch sind und wissen einfach
ging hoch das ist so unfassbar
einfach krank
knapp 10
sofort fällt allerdings eben hier meine
kritik abholen weil ja ich muss ein
stativ noch holen weil die dachten dass
ein schlagstock
das ist mal
deshalb weil angeblich ein schlagstock
wie gewonnen hat